Hola, soy Michael Shermer, director de la Skeptics Society,
editora de la revista Skeptic.
Investigamos alegatos de eventos paranormales, pseudociencias,
grupos marginales, cultos y todo lo que está en el medio.
Ciencias, pseudociencias, ciencia basura,
ciencia voodoo, ciencia patológica, mala ciencia, no ciencias
y el conocido sin sentido.
A menos que hayan estado en Marte últimamente
sabrán que hay mucho de eso ahí afuera.
Alguna gente nos llama los refutadores lo cual es un término algo negativo,
pero aceptémoslo, hay un montón de basura.
Somos como el escuadrón de calidad del departamento de policía refutando
la basura, bueno, más o menos como los Ralph Naders de las malas ideas,
(Risas)
tratando de reemplazar malas ideas por buenas ideas.
Les muestro un ejemplo de una mala idea.
Traje esto conmigo,
nos lo dió Dateline, de NBC, para probarlo.
Lo produce la Quadro Corporation de Virginia Occidental,
se llama el Quadro 2000 Dowser Rod.
(Risas)
Esto estaba siendo vendido a los directores de escuelas por 900 dólares cada uno.
Es un pedazo de plástico con una antena de Radioshack pegada.
Pueden hacer uno de estos para buscar todo tipo de cosas, pero este en especial
se diseñó para buscar marihuana en los casilleros de los estudiantes.
(Risas)
Así funciona, van caminando por el pasillo y ven si la antena
se mueve hacia un casillero en particular, y entonces abren el casillero.
Es algo así,
les muestro.
(Risas)
Bueno, tiene cierta tendencia de girar hacia la derecha
Esto es ciencia, así que haremos un experimento controlado,
seguro que va para el otro lado.
(Risas)
Señor, ¿podría vaciar sus bolsillos, por favor?
Entonces la pregunta era, ¿puedo encontrar marihuana en los casilleros de los
alumnos? Y la respuesta es, si abren suficientes casilleros, sí.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Pero en ciencia debemos tener en cuenta los errores, no sólo los aciertos
Esa es probablemente la principal lección de mi corta charla aquí, es que
así funcionan todos estos psíquicos, astrólogos, lectores de cartas de tarot y
demás: La gente recuerda los aciertos y olvida los errores.
En ciencia, debemos mantener toda la base de datos
y ver si el número de aciertos de alguna forma es mayor
al número total que usted esperaría por azar.
En este caso, hicimos pruebas.
Teníamos dos cajas opacas,
una con THC marihuana aprobada por el gobierno, y la otra vacía.
Funcionó el 50% de las veces,
justo lo que esperarían lanzando una moneda.
Ese es sólo un pequeño y divertido ejemplo del tipo de cosas que hacemos;
Skeptic es una publicación trimestral,
cada una tiene un tema particular, como esta, es sobre el futuro de la inteligencia.
¿La gente se está volviendo más inteligente o más tonta?
Tengo una opinión propia al respecto, por el negocio en el que estoy.
Pero, de hecho, resulta que la gente se está volviendo más inteligente
Tres puntos de CI (IQ) por cada 10 años que pasan,
lo cual es una cosa interesante.
Con ciencia, no piensen en el escepticismo como una cosa o incluso en la
ciencia como una cosa ¿Son la ciencia y la religión compatibles?
Es como preguntar si la ciencia y la plomería son compatibles.
Son, simplemente, cosas diferentes.
La ciencia no es una cosa, es un verbo.
Es una forma de pensar acerca de las cosas,
Es una forma de buscar una explicación natural a todos los fenómenos.
Me refiero a, ¿qué es más probable?
¿Que inteligencias extraterrestres o seres multidimensionales hayan viajado
la vastedad del espacio interestelar para dejar una marca en las cosechas
en el la granja de Bob en Puckerbrush, Kansas para promover Skeptic.com, nuestro sitio web?
¿o es más probable que un lector de Skeptic haya hecho esto con Photoshop?
En cualquier caso, tenemos que preguntar
(Risas)
cuál es la explicación más probable,
y antes de decir que algo es de fuera de este mundo,
tenemos que asegurarnos de que no está en este mundo
¿Qué es más probable?
¿Que Arnold haya tenido un poco de ayuda extraterrestre en las elecciones para
gobernador, o que el World Weekly News invente cosas?
(Risas)
Y parte de eso, el mismo tema, se expresa muy bien
en esta caricatura de Sidney Harris.
Para aquellos en el fondo, dice: "Entonces sucede un milagro".
"Creo que deberías ser más explícito en el paso dos".
Esta diapositiva, sola, desmantela completamente los argumentos sobre el
diseño inteligente. No es nada más que eso.
(Aplausos)
Pueden decir "Entonces un milagro sucede",
sólo que eso no explica nada,
no ofrece nada, no hay nada para probar.
Es el fin de la conversación para los creacionistas de diseño inteligente.
Mientras que, es cierto, la ciencia a veces pone nombres tentativos
para llenar el espacio lingüistico, energía oscura o materia oscura, o algo así.
Hasta que descubramos qué es lo llamaremos así.
Es el comienzo de la cadena causal para la ciencia.
para el creacionismo de diseño inteligente es el fin de la cadena.
Entonces, podemos preguntarnos esto, ¿qué es más probable?
¿Ovnis, platillos voladores, errores cognitivos perceptuales o incluso engaños?
Esta es la foto de un ovni desde mi casa en Altadena, California,
mirando hacia Pasadena.
Y si se ve muy parecido a un plato desechable, es porque eso es.
Ni siquiera necesitan Photoshop ni equipos de alta tecnología,
no necesitan computadoras.
Esto fue tomado con una cámara Kodak desechable.
Alguien está al costado con el plato listo para tirarlo,
la cámara está lista, ya está.
(Risas)
Aunque es posible que la mayoría de estas cosas sean engaños,
o ilusiones o algo así, y algunas sean reales,
es más probable que todas sean falsas como las marcas en las cosechas.
En un plano más serio, en todas las ciencias buscamos balance
entre datos y teoría.
En el caso de Galileo, él tuvo dos problemas
al mirar con el telescopio hacia Saturno.
Primero, no había una teoría de anillos planetarios y,
segundo, sus datos eran vagos y difusos.
No podía entender muy bien qué era lo que estaba mirando,
entonces escribió lo que vió:
"He observado que el planeta más lejano tiene tres cuerpos".
Esto es lo que terminó concluyendo.
Entonces, sin una teoría de anillos planetarios y sólo datos vagos,
no pueden tener una buena teoría.
Esto no se resolvió sino hasta 1655.
Esto es del libro de Christiaan Huygens, en donde catalogó todos los errores
que las personas hicieron tratando de entender qué pasaba cuando miraban a
Saturno. No fue sino hasta que Huygens tuvo dos cosas:
Una buena teoría de anillos planetarios y de cómo operaba el sistema solar,
y mejores telescopios, mejores datos.
Así pudo entender que lo que ocurría es que la Tierra iba más rápido,
de acuerdo a las leyes de Kepler, que Saturno y después lo alcanzamos
y vemos los anillos en diferentes ángulos, ahí.
Que es lo que de hecho resultó ser cierto.
El problema con tener una teoría
es que su teoría puede estar cargada de sesgos cognitivos.
Entonces uno de los problemas explicando por qué las personas creen cosas
extrañas es que tenemos cosas a un nivel más simple
y después ire a otras más serias
como, tenemos una tendencia a ver caras.
Esta es la cara en Marte que era,
en 1976, donde había todo un movimiento para que la NASA
tomara fotografías del área, porque la gente pensaba
que era una monumental arquitectura hecha por marcianos.
Bueno, resultó que, acá hay un acercamiento del 2001,
si entrecierran los ojos todavía pueden ver la cara.
Cuando entrecierran los ojos lo que están haciendo es
cambiando de alta calidad a baja calidad,
reduciendo así la calidad de los datos.
Y si no les dijera qué buscar, todavía podrían ver la cara,
porque estamos programados por la evolución para reconocer rostros.
Los rostros son importantes para nosotros a nivel social.
Y claro, caras felices,
caras de todo tipo son fáciles de ver.
(Risas)
Pueden ver la cara feliz en Marte ahí.
Si los astrónomos fuesen ranas quizás verían a la rana René,
la ven ahí,
con patitas de rana...
O si los geólogos fuesen elefantes...
Iconografía religiosa,
(Risas)
descubierta por un pastelero en Tennesee en 1996,
cobraba 5 dólares por cabeza para verla
hasta que recibió una orden del abogado de la madre Teresa.
Esta es la Virgen de Guadalupe y la Virgen de Watsonville, acá bajando la calle
o subiendo la calle desde acá.
Las ramas de árboles con particularmente buenas porque son irregulares,
en blanco y negro, borrosas y pueden buscar patrones;
los humanos somos animales buscadores de patrones.
Aquí está la Virgen María en una ventana de vidrio en Sao Paulo.
Aquí la Virgen María hizo su aparicion en un sándwich de queso
que incluso pude sostener en un casino en las Vegas...
Claro, esto es Estados Unidos...
(Risas)
Este casino pagó 28.500 dólares en eBay por el sándwich de queso
¿Pero realmente a quién se parece? ¿a la Virgen María?
(Risas)
Tiene esos labios de los años 40...
La Virgen María en Clearwater, Florida.
Esta pude verla...
Hay un montón de personas, los creyentes que vienen,
sillas de ruedas y muletas y así.
Fuimos a investigar,
para darles idea del tamaño, ese es Dawkins, yo y el asombroso Randi
junto a esta imagen de dos, dos pisos y medio.
Muchas velas, miles de velas que la gente deja de tributo.
Entonces caminamos a la parte de atrás para ver qué estaba pasando aquí,
resulta que donde sea hay un rociador y una palmera
se obtiene este efecto.
Aquí está la virgen María en la parte de atrás, la cual empezaron a limpiar...
Parece que sólo pueden tener un milagro por edificio.
(Risas)
Entonces, ¿realmente es el milagro de María o es el milagro de Marge?
Voy a terminar con otro ejemplo de esto
con audio, ilusiones auditivas.
Está esta película "Voces del Más Allá"
con Michael Keaton sobre los muertos hablándonos...
Por cierto, este negocio de hablar con los muertos, no es tan complicado,
cualquiera puede hacerlo; pero resulta
que lograr que los muertos respondan, esa es la parte difícil.
(Risas)
En este caso, supuestamente estos mensajes están escondidos en fenómenos
electrónicos. Está esta página, reversespeech.com, de donde bajé esto.
Aquí está la versión normal, este es uno de los más famosos,
esta es la versión normal de una canción muy famosa...
¿uno podría escuchar esto todo el día, cierto?
(Risas)
Aquí está al revés.
A ver si pueden entender el mensaje que está supuestamente ahí..
¿Qué entendieron?
(Audiencia: Satán)
Shermer: ¿Satán? ok, por lo menos escuchamos Satán.
Ahora voy a preparar a la parte auditiva de su cerebro
para decirle qué se supone que escuche y lo escucharemos de nuevo.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
No pueden dejar de escucharlo cuando les digo que está ahí.
(Risas)
Déjenme terminar con una historia positiva...
Skeptics es una organización educacional sin fines de lucro,
siempre buscamos cositas buenas que la gente hace.
En Inglaterra hay una cantante de pop,
una cantante muy popular hoy en Inglaterra, Katie Melua.
Ella escribió una hermosa canción que
estuvo en el top 5 en el 2005 llamada "Nine Millon Bicycles in Beijing" (nueve
millones de bicicletas en Beijing). Es una historia de amor, ella es como la Norah
Jones de Reino Unido. Es sobre cuánto ama a su novio,
y lo compara con nueve millones de bicicletas y así...
Y tiene este pasaje
Bueno, eso es bonito.
Por lo menos estuvo cerca.
En Estados Unidos sería estamos a 6000 años luz del borde
(Risas)
Pero mi amigo Simon Singh, físico de partículas que ahora se dedica
a la divulgación científica, escribió el libro "el Big Bang",
usa cada oportunidad que tiene para promover la buena ciencia.
Entonces escribió un artículo acerca de la canción de Katie en The Guardian
diciendo, mm, bueno, sabemos exactamente a cuánto estamos del borde
Son 13.7 mil millones de años-luz, no es una suposición,
lo sabemos dentro de margenes de error bien definidos.
Entonces podemos decirlo, aunque sin certeza absoluta, es bastante cercano
a ser verdad. Y para crédito suyo, Katie llamó un poco después de la aparición
del artículo. Dijo: "Estoy muy avergonzada,
era miembro del club de astronomía, debí de haberlo sabido".
Grabó de nuevo la canción,
entonces voy a terminar con la nueva versión.
(Aplausos)
¿Acaso no es esto genial?